[Musique]
bonsoir à tous vous êtes sur ces huit
bienvenue en vidant des terriens du
samedi avec monsieur thierry ardisson
évidemment monsieur law
le principe est très simple toute
l'année j'ai regardé décortiqué analysé
les terriens et ce soir on fait le grand
bilan en rentrant au coeur de la bête si
on reprend la chronologie de l'émission
on a débriefé yann moix après les yann
moix qu'est ce qui se passait à chocques
gens qui adorent 7 d'or shopi alors je
pille a eu plein d'invités en promo vous
avez fait de très belles rencontres
syrie beaucoup de nouveaux invités qui
ne vous connaissais pas et que vous ne
connaissez pas jamy gourmaud pio marmaï
céline sallette philippe lachaux michel
fau monsieur poulpe albert ivanoff mais
shopping qu'est ce que c'est voilà parce
que un artiste c'est aussi un
code-barres
c'est comme super mercier s'est dit
choqué
[Musique]
il se marie avec zazie elle a pas l'air
tout à fait d'accord au conseil les
codes barres c'est un peu moins artiste
qua non mais peut-être que laurent à une
meilleure définition du shopping hôtel
alors monsieur coutu la jeune gauche pas
mais je sais bien alors monsieur ping
shopping c'est vous vendez votre truc ok
d'accord les gens vont et viennent dans
leur truc c'est shopping avant sa mère
ça s'appelle de la télévision
mais cette émission
parmi les nouveaux il ya eu johan riou
qui est venu c'est le commentateur foot
sur l'équipe tv le très sympathique
commentateurs ils sont très forts sur
l'équipe tv il faut regarder un mec qui
regarde un match de foot et lui vous
commente ce qu'ils voient c'est un peu
de la radio filmée royaume allez c'est
parti le générique de l'émission et
lancèrent et tous ces visages qui
défilent et ça hier là on va regarder
comme n'aura d'égalé le samedi c'est
très beau tirer à 10 ans qui salue
évidemment les téléspectateurs en
rappelant le slogan l'émission
l'émission qui vous aide à faire votre
porte et on s'appelle la reprise à la
30e un incroyable elle rentre dans le
stade il ya 55 multi capteurs qui sont
en train de regarder l'émission il a
fallu neuf ans qui est en tête en
descendant l'escalier celui de michel
cymes et françois xavier demaison qui
lui suce la roue comme on dit à olivier
et ça y est attention il yal'euro
graphie l'europa fils à qui est un petit
peu larbitre là attention mais c'est
l'arbitré qui tacle c'est à l'arbitré me
faire du mal attention il a salué les
affaires qui cède un petit peu de
contrôle arbitres les bad guys adverse à
castellar 10 ans qui a arrêté la musique
avec la main comme il le fera rien sans
un binaire lev yachine c'est hugo loris
et là ça y est les joueurs un petit peu
sur le terrain qui se regarde un petit
peu attention c'est le souhait ans au
sourire le hassania thierry ardisson est
en train d'évoquer le fait que lui et
46e au classement des animateurs
préférés que michel cymes c'est promis
je sois la déception dans le visage de
tir à 10,5 simone et irritable soyez de
retirer vous êtes 46e tout le monde
frappe à la porte pour que dans ses
placements il est 46e d'agacements quand
même où il ya des grandes personnes où
il ya des grands noms il devrait être
content quand je suis né pas allez c'est
parti c'est maman quand attendu de la
miss la séance de tirs au but comme
l'eyetoy film musical blind test lui
panaf contre lembeye est-ce que parfip à
89,9 tradition c'est pas de chance on
s'est lancé
attention ces magnifiques manoeuvre
salut comment ils appréhendent une
seconde à easy savais qu'il me qu'ils
sont nous c'est laurent baffie qui a
dégoûté voyager à laurent baffie qui est
un petit peu triste de ne pas gâcher sa
nouvelle filiale dont il peut égaliser
alors dire trop mais je plais à l'ats
l'office est magnifique avec monsieur
albert zafy pas refuser la rue montana
encore y avait 0 à 0 2 et puis après à 2
2 3 à 2 c'est absolument comme liverpool
et tottenham incroyable partie son pet
heureux évidemment d'échelle duel tu es
le soleil
[Applaudissements]
un grand merci à yoann ryu ken au bond à
l'équipe qui nous a accueillis dans le
bref studio c'est le voit studio où ils
font les matches bravo bravo à l'équipe
ses suppléments vraiment
[Applaudissements]
aller on regarde le best-of de toutes
ces nouvelles rencontres qui ont eu lieu
cette année philippe lachaux bonsoir
disait beau gosse
il est drôle
maintenant avec votre nouveau film nicky
larson vous êtes musclée
vous avez une super meuf qu'on a reçues
ici elodie fontan vo film explose le box
office et énervante
ce qui énerve encore plus et quand on
veut avec elodie là c'est terrible je
vous ai l'air de tellement bien vous
entendre mais elle n'était pas avec
ya deux semaines tulle avec l'été avant
je ne sais pas du tout elle a traîné un
peu partout j'étais
comme
laurent c'est la première fois qu'il
vient et la dernière
soit gentil
alors il ya aussi un truc qui m'énerve
c'est vos nouveaux muscles oh là là là
regardez la photo là c'est à dire que
oui je suis plus comme à gauche
maintenant
avec ses très ingrat la musculation
c'est vrai que j'ai fait du sport pour
le rôle parce que je devais interpréter
un rôle créé un personnage cousteau de
voilages et ça m'a pris huit mois
beaucoup de blanc de beaucoup de poulet
et rappelons que la [__] n'est pas un
musée
saint-raymond riche en typhon qui aurait
déposé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez un truc qui cloche
c'est ça magnéto serge
[Musique]
et
explique le groupe c'est une petite
vengeance d'elodie bien presté ça sur
ces réseaux et voilà la seule élégance
qu'elle a eue c'est qu'elle a coupé la
vidéo là mais parce que normalement
c'est filmé la voix le paquet se
balancer ah oui mais là c'est le seul
voilà la classe qu'elle a fait mais
récupéré un stade qu'il y aura vengeance
on attend la vengeance avec un parce que
j'ai un beau gosse
chien bourgault bon feeling car si la
saison des récompenses on va voir si
vous êtes prêt à ne pas en avoir on va
faire une interview pas de césar
ah la la
[Musique]
bible à chaud vous êtes ici ce soir
parce que vous venez de ne pas recevoir
de césar du meilleur film pour nicky
larson
c'est déjà le quatrième césar que vous
ne recevez pas est-ce que c'est toujours
la même émotion
absolument j'avais un travail dur pour
justement rater cette récompense et
c'est pas si simple est-ce que c'est
déjà un honneur ne pas être nommé
absolument thierry
on finit par s'habituer quand même vous
serez descendre dans la rue et j'étais
de l'année dernière césar du public
voilà et j'étais le troisième film qui
avait fait le plus d'entrées donc j'ai
quand même vu mon film à la cérémonie
voilà bientôt très intense et puissant
est-ce que vous avez une pensée pour
tous ceux qui ont eu un césar et qui
sont dégoûtés à l'heure qu'il est
oui enfin c'est des petites pensées
parce que je pense que ils sont pas de
trop trop trop dégoûté non non c'est pas
ça fait plaisir de recevoir cette soirée
plaisir
évidemment enfin je t'encourage à mais
oui je sais je sais je sais très bien
mais non les films qui marchent et qui
font rire les entendra enfin tous ceux
qui font de la comédie étudiants pour
nous le plus important est évidemment de
faire lui le public tendance alors
j'imagine que ça fait longtemps que vous
rêvez de ne pas avoir de césar ça fait
30 ans que qu'est ce que tu veux
répondre ah
oui ça fait longtemps que je parle des
césars parce que après on risquerait de
me proposer d'autres genres de films et
moi je veux faire des comédies voilà
c'était bien parti pour ça j'ai lu dans
le magazine le point que philippe était
considéré comme nous ferons 6 le beurre
mais alors ça si c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai c'est un truc de ouf mais c'est un
truc tout ce que moi celui qui m'a donné
envie de faire ce métier c'est francis
veber avec pierre richard bah voila je
voyais mes parents rire devant ses films
dans le canapé donc je connais les films
par coeur et je vais même remercier du
coup au générique de baby sitting j'ai
dit merci francis veber est épié des
chars pour m'avoir envie de faire ce
métier voilà
est ce que vous espérez qu'un jour on
vous donne pas un césar pour l'ensemble
de votre oeuvre mais le graal ce serait
de ne pas avoir de ce carcan oui oui
c'est ça c'est ça j'espère surtout ne
jamais avoir d'oscar pas du tout non
mais c'est surtout pas après obligé de
tourner avec brad pitt dicaprio tous les
gens dont je suis fan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
michaud a
déterminé un comédien exceptionnel tu
peux absolument tout jouer même les
comédiens en vous regardant femmes comme
un magnéto serge merci non ce que vous
me donnez est immense
c'est la quête de toute une vie et à
travers moi c'est la grande famille du
théâtre que vous honorez et je voudrais
bien sûr remercié madeleine sologne
madeleine situe dans la salle pardon
pardon
ce n'est pas mon mot lien ce n'est pas
mon molière non bien sûr c'est le moyen
de toute l'équipe non
où
et son culot
so trop savoir ce qui se passait dans le
faux
elle conte matures
mais
encore
c'est quelqu'un qui va dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très heureux de les avoir sur mon
plateau chaque photo est un génie soyons
au sol
alors vite le travestissement fait
partie de l'histoire du théâtre c'est le
kabuki c'est le théâtre élisabéthain et
dès l'antiquité dans les pièces de
plaute les femmes étaient jouées par des
hommes non c'est pas c'est pas nouveau
et puis après au 19e siècle c'était les
femmes qui jouent et les jeunes hommes
hamlet lorenzaccio ces jeux par des
femmes alors vous reprocher à notre
époque son manque d'extravagance et vous
dites les jeunes comédiens je tousse un
peu comme à la télé ou au bureau vous
avez raison non même les vieux aussi
oui il ya un peu tout le monde joue un
peu pareil enfin c'est ça alors que je
pense il ya pas un jeu qui est plus
légitime que l'autre il ya des notions
de style alors vous passez sans cesse
d'un répertoire à l'autre vous dites
n'appartenir à aucune chapelle est un
combat ah oui je me sens un peu seul
mais je pense que c'est albert camus
disait qu'on est toujours seul donc je
pense que c'est le lot de l'artiste mais
en effet mais j'arrive encore à trouver
des producteurs et des comédiens qui
m'accompagne pour faire des spectacles
donc pour l'instant ça va vous avez une
réputation d' avenir un peu dans le
métier ah oui il ya des gens qui ne
supportent pas aimer mais comme disait
sacha guitry être aimé par tout le monde
s'est tramé par n'importe qui donc a
envie d'être aimé par les vaincus
alors corinne rebond soir
vous avez déclaré je suis la fille de ta
région la coiffeuse de ton village
l'esthéticienne de ta petite ville de
province je suis une chanteuse à la
choule peroxydée voilà ça déjà c'est
votre définition on peut quand même
félicité elie semoun
on se fait baiser à chaque fois il est
très fort alors vous êtes la nouvelle it
girl dont réclamer aussi bien dans les
nuits cannoises que dans l'after du
défilé chanel vous nous parlerait de
votre premier album un air de fête donc
par l'arrêt de t-shirts de paillettes de
boule à facettes et de néo disco
[Applaudissements]
ça
bon alors tout a commencé en fait quand
vous aviez 14 alors matin vous allez
chez le boulanger monsieur georges ans
vous cherchez des dépôts des petits
pains aux raisins et il vous donne ses
chouquettes
corinne tombe sur une annonce troupe de
théâtre cherche comédiens amateurs tout
a commencé comme ça on peut complètement
dans mon village de rogne parce que je
suis né au creusot j'aime à le dire il
manque un jeu
brogniart alors qu'est ce qui se passe
non et donc oui je tombe sur cette
troupe l'atelier du possible voilà je
commence à 14,1 et puis jusqu'à 20 ans
on a fait vraiment du théâtre de
tréteaux et on allait de village en
village et c'est comme ça j'ai commencé
la semaine des as 19 ans montait à paris
et là
c'est le drame pas du tout dans notre
foi dans la journée vous êtes caissier à
la fnac et le soir déchanter je sais
tout ça c'est bon vous pouvez pas pu
faire plus plaisir comment vous savez ça
va les trente ans comme dit ça je mandat
sparrow mais
méfions nous chanter dans des cabarets
des chansons de bourvil et de reggiani
chantier coin robin l'opérer juin ayant
ville j'ai vraiment une chanson qui est
importante pour moi qui s'appelle ma
petite chanson qu'est ce qu'elle a mais
qu'est ce qu'elle a ma
petite chance
qu'est-ce qu'elle n'a mais qu'est ce
qu'elle n'a plus mme marc petit chansons
qui ne te plait plus lourd
[Applaudissements]
vérifiez que vous avez bien fermer votre
porte qu'il n'y a personne caché sous le
lit que les couteaux sont bien rangés à
leur place voici le roi tu vivre qui
fait peur maxime chattam
maxime chattam
25 romans compteur 7 millions de livres
vendus est absolument incroyable des
traductions dans 20 pays on vous
surnomme le stephen king français le
prince du thriller ou publié chez albin
michel le signal on va en parler tout à
l'heure les protagonistes du roman
s'appelle les spencer il ressemble
étrangement au chatham lui est un
dramaturge elle était animatrice de télé
évidemment on pense à votre femme
faustine bollaert n'ont aucune
imagination
fait j'ai fait 25 fois le même bouquin
non mais c'est vrai tous les soirs je
faisais lire les chapitres à ma femme
qui moins bien mais enfin c'est moi quoi
laisser les gens vont penser que je veux
vraiment arrêter mon métier du coin à ne
pas arrêter maintenant à me paraît t
elle devrait
c'est très bizarre à la maison parce que
ça par exemple cette photo c'est quand
vous découpez des fraises par exemple
mais je crois que dans la famille on a
une déformation peut pas faire les
choses normalement voilà c'est ça ça
c'est qu'on veut ce team présente sa sa
petite dernière
qui est une poupée dans mon bureau et
les enfants l'adorent aller votre
cabinet de curiosité c'est quelque chose
parce qu'il ya des trucs de fou et on
sait jamais si c'est vrai ou si ces
fonds étaient enfants voient ça ouais
migrants ils ont grandi là dedans mais
tu ne t en fais serial killer dont si
laurent blanc ils vont jouer les gens
maintenant laurent regarde les enfants
ils apprennent à jouer ils ont le lego
freddy kruger
non non c'est vrai il ya le lego freddy
kruger et ya le lego hannibal lecter
aussi est pas mal du tout aimé les
enfants se rendent pas compte ils
pensent qu'ils jouent avec un petit
personnel se bat pour les enfants c'est
pour cette pauvre faustine que que je
plains de tout mon coeur je savais juste
un truc elle est pire que moi ah bon on
a préparé notre mariage on est parti
pour faire un mariage blanc machin etc
et un moment se regarde et me dit on est
en train de faire un truc qui ne
ressemble pas ça ne me ressemble pas ré
et elle m'a dit je vais te proposer
quelque chose et on a fait un match dans
l'esprit tim burton dans un manoir hanté
exactement et là on a la photo du gâteau
de mariage à part c'était réellement
sommet de publier pour vos six ans de
mariage donc sur instagram alors pour
mémoire quand même ce qu'il faut dire et
ça justifie ce que vous venez de dire
c'est que faustine pour son mémoire de
fin d'étude elle était allée passer huit
jours dans une morgue en compagnie des
thanatopracteurs pour maquiller décor
ouais ouais mais bon je pense qu'ils ont
été faits pour se rencontrer je dois
être sympa les tiroirs et vaut à la
première rencontre elle a tout de suite
vu vous étiez faits l'un pour l'autre
bah ouais odeur de putréfaction
double charme a opéré voilà une photo de
faustine bollaert dans sa piscine et qu
envoyé cette photo est ce que vous
l'imaginez
poignardé par un clown avec le sang
partout dans la piscine non c'est ma
femme je laime
non ceci dit un jour ça faisait
peut-être un an qu'on était qu'on était
ensemble elles reposent 1/2 streller
moyens mais tu as déjà tué quelqu'un non
mais pour de vrai
monsieur poule pour re bonsoir bonsoir
ce monsieur poulpe
ducloy ses bras tentaculaires sur canal+
vous êtes le symbole vous êtes l'icône
du reboot créative de la chaîne voilà
pour moi vous est ce à dire que canal
brun et là d'un seul coup vous incarnez
finalement une renaissance de canal+
combien je vous dois attirer combien je
vous dois pour ça on va taper un élan
chalon à dornach dans la tradition
d'antoine de caunes il ya manqué
iconique lui aussi de canal+ alors vous
appeler monsieur poule parce que vous
étiez mou je me suis toujours mes
paroles i j'espère après
ça dépend avec vous peut-être une mine
hoyle peut-être que ça c'est pas
attention à ne pas provoquer
[Musique]
alors crac crac une fois par mois c'est
pas beaucoup à la latte et après
l'accord à faire un peu plus dans la
vraie vie dans ma vraie vie sinon le
pitch de crac crac sur canal c'est le
sexe pénètre partout et même là où on ne
l'attend pas non mais c'est vrai on
s'est rendu compte qu'en fait tout et
sexualisé partout dans notre société et
le l'idée c'était de liste et un petit
peu tout ce qui nous entoure et et notre
rapport au sexe par rapport à toutes ces
choses que ce soit le sport la politique
laurent là toutes ces choses là qu'on a
envie de pénétrer
alors vu qu'il a huit tentacules je ne
dirais pas donc vous traitez d'encre à
crack de sexe et politique sexe et
humour sexe et féminisme c'est que c'est
paranormal c'est quand même assez
intéressante et une super émission qu'il
faut voir je suis allé à los angeles me
faire branler par des fantômes bon
d'accord je crois qu on est copains toi
de là alors la prochaine c'est le 10
avril oui comment parler aux ados de
leur sexualité et la punchline c'est
quand ken doit-il mérité son prénom
c'est bien alors vous dites c'est une
émission rentrer dedans mais qui ne se
lave pas les mains avant bah oui on
essaie de rendre ça un peu chic mais
enfin mettre un peu crado quoi alors une
émission sans tabou sans jugement sans
chemise et son pantalon
vous avez le sens de la punchline mais
c'est pareil c'était pour montrer que je
voulais absolument mouiller la chemise
dans cette émission n'est pas juste
rester sur mon plateau et aller aussi
dans la vie on va voir g notre offre je
jouais bien de quoi vous allez voir mais
on va arriver on va arriver à mary la
vague alors il ya un décor et que
beaucoup de velours des lumières
feutrées une ambiance ce poste par tous
un peu injustement alors vous parler de
littérature dans cette émission dans une
séquence qui s'appelle le book club il
ya aussi un reportage dans une boîte
anglaise qui fait des chocolats mous les
sur des anus
n'y a pas de chocolat blanc non
si tu veux c'est incroyable et lui là où
il est génial c'est qu'il paye de sa
personne doit s'accaparer ouais elle
était allé en angleterre / bien une
matière première ouais pour faire les
choses et ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que donc il se fait mouler la
linth quand même ce que j'ai elle fera
ce que tu dis pas tous les jours et un
aspect noir la mersey brière c'est beau
les lanières ce moment là il ya une star
qui l'appelle et c'est là que je me suis
dit quand même bravo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors bilal assadi bonsoir
vous être enfin enfin sur mon plateau ça
fait des semaines et vous le savez que
je vous attends magnéto serge
j'ai le bienvenu quand tu veux dans
cette émission tu seras reçu bilal comme
un roi
parce que je préfère bilal chez vous
tivo gymnich quand vous dites bonsoir
pareil ça j'adore est ce que vous pouvez
me faire pour moi un spécial bon soit
pareil bon score paritaire
j'adore j'adore et que notre nom manitou
serge
bonsoir paris
bonsoir
je
vois pas
qu'est
bon s'emballer
pas mal pas mal gré des besoins comment
saisir bonsoir paris
qu'elle soit paris et les publics 3,4
[Applaudissements]
emballe pas mal pas mal
vous avez bien sûr
compris comment c'est possible ça je
m'entraîne à ça depuis des années pour
d'idées pour mes peluche plutôt que je
faisais des concerts quand j'étais petit
mes tenues été faites avec du papier
toilette et mes perruques avec des
serviettes de bain mais alors bien
commencé très très très jeunes envoient
en parlait d'ailleurs les perruques par
exemple les neuf ans quand vous tombez
sur le clip love gamme de lady gaga et
ça a été le déclic ça ça a été ça a été
l'un des déclics j'ai eu beaucoup de
déclic je commençais déjà à vouloir
avoir des cheveux longs des très petits
même quand j'avais 4 5 ans on a encore
des vidéos de moi qui courais partout
dans la maison j'avais juste ma couche
et une serviette sur la tête et puis je
voulais avoir des cheveux longs comme
les princesses disney et tout mais c'est
vrai quand j'ai vu ce clip donc je vois
lady gaga qui
s'affirme dans visuellement et
musicalement et je me suis dit waouh on
a le droit j'aimerais faire ça et je
sens leur clip de brassens n'a pas donné
envie de te laisser pousser la moustache
mais peut-être peut-être un jour alors
aux sexualités bleus vais assumer très
tôt dès l'âge de 13 ans j'ai quand même
chose en route le plus précoces de
l'histoire en vrai moi je le sais depuis
bien plus tôt c'est bien plutôt que ça
je me rappelle j'étais en primaire
devais avoir 7 ans et j'étais tombé
amoureux d'un garçon on m'avait pas
encore dit que c'était interdit donc
pour moi c'était normal et puis après on
m'avait expliqué annoncé pas possible tu
peux pas être amoureux d'un garçon il
faudra être à mon stock après interrogé
finalement après même à deux ans de
salaire l'anecdote c'est pas là que
j'allais là-bas
[Applaudissements]
alors
votre mère et qu'elle semblait rami est
toujours ma maman il me laissait faire
un petit peu ce que je voulais elle m'a
pas forcée à faire quelque chose de
quelque chose de telma voyez qu'il y
avait des choses que j'aimais bien par
exemple gmail et poupées barbie et donc
que j'avais le droit à avoir des pleurs
biel n'est pas forcé la voiture parce
que j'allais pas jouer avec de toute
façon elle voulait juste que je sois
heureux
alors en 4e votre meilleure amie vers
elle que vous avez eu une aventure avec
un garçon à l'internât vous êtes exclu a
effectivement vous allez voir votre mère
pour lui annoncer votre renvoi est super
cool elle vous dit fais jamais seul
ouais ouais ok d'accord ouais ouais
voilà va faire la vaisselle et j'étais
très très surpris je mate parce que
j'adore je pense que je suis pas le seul
mais quand on quand on ait ce genre de
choses annoncées on se fait la scène
plusieurs fois dans sa tête avant on a
très très peur on imagine le tir et
quand la réponse et va faire la
vaisselle jetable un peu déçu ça vous
dit quelque chose alors aujourd'hui tout
va bien tout va très bien j'étais avec
nos fans
d'où ça sort cliquer au courant de ça
moi
oui oui quel mal y at il à sa n'ya pas
de mal c'est juste un peu bizarre de
d'accord bah oui oui oui ianao fait tout
se passe bien ça se passe très bien et
vient d'acheter un mac
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours sur sa vie nous
sommes toujours dans le groupe il en
était rien du samedi avec un port est
monsieur tierra mission
bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et laurent baffie
[Applaudissements]
la cage aux folles la cades jean-paul un
point pour moi vas-y freenautes film
allez on passe en revue toute la saison
en essayant un petit peu d'analysé tout
ce qui s'est passé on vient de voir tous
les nouveaux invités qui n'était jamais
venu chez thierry ardisson et il ya
aussi a contrario plein de vieux copains
qui sont même après c'est plus sympa il
ya ceux qui reviennent tous les ans
comme le calendrier des pompiers ou les
impôts et bref plein de copains mais
quand on reçoit des vieux copains on est
discret sur leur âge vous avez 64 ans
ouais
[Musique]
et contient bon filon on utilise les 64
berges ouais bravo ouais c'est déjà pas
mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
24 ans
d'ailleurs il ya les copains qui ne
savent pas du tout se tenir
rappelez-vous pierre arditi il s'est un
petit peu comme on dirait elle fait
plaisir sous la table
est très bizarre
pour moi c'est lamentable c'est la vente
à ces mamans carrière lambert wilson lui
s'est soulagé sous la table
c'est forcément à cause de sa mort
alors je vous rassure encore la joie a
salué la qualité du bruitage
[Applaudissements]
alors cette année seriez vous avez
retrouvé plein de copains que vous aviez
pas reçu depuis longtemps et vous étiez
très contents de les recevoir et ça se
voyait gérard chi très heureux très
heureux de vous retrouver merci thierry
à mousson
c'est cool c'est mignon à lorraine nord
alors ok dodo qu'on s'est pas vu depuis
longtemps qu est-ce qu on sera content
bas mot rien de spécial je vous rassure
les conversations de stars c'est
exactement les mêmes que les vieux
tonton à noël avec l âge soixante dix à
bâle a battu les fait pas
franchement tu fait soixante huit mois
maximum je défends effet 69 m
mais du coup quand on s'est pas vu
depuis longtemps on se raconte leur vie
on se parle de nouvelles femmes que que
l'autre ne connaît pas d'ailleurs et
puis surtout on espère qu'ils regardent
pas la télé sinon elle va apprendre des
gros dossiers de l'été filiale avec
alain oui mais bel et bien bravo les
films parce que moi je le connais
c'est énorme et du coup cette génération
un petit peu de baby boomer que vous
êtes là plein de points communs comme
celle d'être avec une femme plus jeune
et du coup c'est bien ça vous fait des
points comme en quoi votre femme regarde
oui on s'attend à trouver ma fait jurer
de pas draguer elle a 30 ans de moins de
vous 34 aïe aïe aïe battu mais on va
dépasser le tout pas mieux vous savez
quand s'est marié le même jour à wil 21
juin 2014 avec la même
bordel non mais ce que tu ne sais pas
c'est qu'il ya pratiquement la même
différence d'âge entre candice et vous
et audrey moi oui c'est à nous ça nous
les générations c'est une relique seule
une seule
[Applaudissements]
qui donne
à son restaurant mais qu'est ce que veut
venger sa fille jeu propre à marier les
serveurs à rennes on appris mais c'est
bien parce que parfois on trouve des
points communs mais à la con j'adorerais
passer l'aspirateur ça me fait ça me
console je veux dire parce que j'aime
pas voir traîner des trucs comme vous je
suis maniaque je le fais moi-même je
demande à tous les deux
j'ai exactement comme ça intègre l
aspirateur
thierry qu'ils passent l'aspirateur
[Musique]
non
je passe l'aspirateur en l'icm tués lors
toute l'année vous avez fait des jeux et
surtout des blind test et pour un bon
blindtest qu'est-ce qu'il faut il faut
une main une main magique
[Musique]
et même après 25 ans de gymnich tir il
est encore capable de se surprendre
lui-même
travaille à un clavier ça marche de
l'autre côté aussi fait voir des douars
remetez moi tout ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marche et que les deux mon travail quand
la force est avec vous savez pas dans ça
doit être génial d'avoir un super
pouvoir tirer
tout côté emma
il s'investit incroyable sa mort mais
pourquoi ils font pas un bar veille sur
toi je sais pas mais moi j'ai découvert
ce donc dans une émission il était deux
heures du matin dans tout le monde en
parle à l'époque tu as vendu les droits
ou c'est à toi non parce que les autres
essayent personne n'y arrive si tu veux
[Applaudissements]
c'est marrant les gens essayent alors
ils essayent y en a qui réussissent mais
vous connaissez l'histoire du mec qui a
une grande gueule mais qui passe pour un
con c'est maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
interne
moi ça marche pas alors là c'était en
2010 ça vous rassure il ya 15 ans tu
l'avais déjà pas ce pouvoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
le pire c'est que je crois que tu es le
seul qui ne s'est pas arrêté la musique
à la main
[Musique]
ouais
c'est hyper cuisson car ça ils arrêtent
et c'est encore plus fort que le
déclencher bah oui moi je déconne mais
j'arrête
ça y est on y est
non non violent qui fera sa à l'ehpad
oui pour faire il sortait de musique de
l'accordéon roulé dessus
[Musique]
non ça compte barça compte bataclan
c'est le seul moyen que celle de faire
cette dernière attend on est en berne et
sa musique
[Musique]
bon à la fin du blind test de cette
année il ya eu des célébrations a baissé
les bras et n'a pas déclenché non non
non non mais tu ne s'est pas arrêtée en
plus une déclenché plus je prends
les paris ils se déclenchent
[Rires]
j'en aurai un jour je donnerais belle
célébration
bah oui à la fin des blocages de cette
année il ya eu des célébrations tel un
footballeur la personne devait courir
comme s'il venait de marquer un but en
finale de la coupe du monde alors qu'en
réalité mais juste de trouver ta taille
elio d'annie cordy et parfois eu la
discorde les règles du jeu changent avec
arrière oui donc le jeu s'appelle ali
foccart et elle gagne non pas du tout
pas du tout envie car ils gagnent
simplement que tu les vois rien d'autre
à faire la célébration de foot je
préférerais que ce soit toi
c'est vrai sauf que le drame est arrivé
[Musique]
c'est bon
t'es un marrant car
après elle a 37 ans selon wikipedia
aussi maintenant tout cas on l'a plus
revu sur aucun plateau télé on embrasse
son médecin légiste alors oui le nouveau
jeu de cette année pour celui qui
gagnait à blind test était de faire une
célébration de foot sauf que parfois
entre le foot la boxe et l'ultimate
fighting il n'y a qu'un pas magnéto
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le baron
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
salut
je suis tombé en charge comme en charge
et finalement j'ai rien vu j'ai gagné
lorsque après j'étais sur lui l'homme à
monsieur alors dans les blind test il ya
des thèmes parfois joyeux par exemple
pseudo c'était un thème qui était joyeux
vais retrouver le nom des voeux des
stars le vrai nom des stars pierru des
blind test avec des thèmes un petit peu
plus
plombant thème du blayais ce soir
l'overdose en hommage à toutes les
idoles de philippe qui sont mortes
d'overdose oui mais c'est sûr sur le
papier c'est pas la rigolade pas se
mentir année encore on invitait blind
test du sida est mort dans un accident
de la route dont 106 après dans les
blinds ce qui est des thèmes en hommage
à nos invités et c'est marrant parce que
des fois tu veux faire plaisir aux gens
eh ben c'est pas reçu comme ça or blanc
une thèse de ce soir est également un
hommage à joey starr
[Applaudissements]
ils nous regardent je vais encore pour
toi mon match et voilà et le blanc intel
s'appelle google ou
[Applaudissements]
c'est faux heureusement vous avez pas
fait blind test les crocos mais parfois
vous avez fait des blind test sur un
thème rigolo le thème de ce soir c'est
les exilés fiscaux
voilà compagnie oui c'est fou tout de
suite on pense à florent pagny un bon il
n'y avait pas que lui charles aznavour
donc exilé fiscal en suisse
plus maintenant évidemment
donc johnny hallyday exilée fiscale en
suisse par plus maintenant c'est moche
sinon comment on pourrait résumer cette
situation devrait sa porte pas chance
non merci et puis à chaque fois que vous
faites un jeu laurent joue pour votre
plus grand bonheur vous êtes sont
supporters numéro un il t'a pas inquiet
de faire une battle contre toi blade 2
oct par lille est pas complètement
derrière donc je suis content attention
l'or reste concentré mon bébé c'est mon
champion fait concentre toi mais vous
savez trouver les mots pour soutenir
votre champion
[Musique]
ma manche et arrête
tu vas retourner les bains non tu vas
retourner là bas
réponse il ya pile jeu fort et trop fort
voilà vous le savez laurent et ton
puisque la balle de tennis et au
labrador il peut pas s'empêcher c'est ça
il peut pas
désolé tu ne peux pas de garder celui
qui l'a non mais
on veut plus faire un blind test
t'imagines que moi thierry ardisson je
ne peux plus faire de blind test parce
qu'il trouve tout à fait renaître au
repos pour thierry c'est vrai pour le
problème à munich sur les blinds t'as
beau lui dire un truc il comprend pas il
comprend pas mais il ya un moment la
cocotte la cocotte aimons tellement elle
a un prénom et
déborde et les morts non mais c'est tout
ça et il ya même des fois où laurent a
carrément été puni
et
saleh
sauf que d'aller au coin bah ça lui
suffit pas non on est obligé de monter
la cocotte la cocotte raymond aimons et
après on est obligé d'appeler le
surveillant général service d'ordre on
attend service d'ordre est ce que tu
peux amener laurent hors de ce qui
deviendra n avoir des consultants avec
faire décoller après tout ce qu'on a
vécu tu veux dire
attention réunion entre nous ce qu'on
aurait partis sauf que scolari viens
d'entendre alors qu'une envie vous
connaissez le proverbe un chat c'est
naturel il revient au galop et balazs à
ses deux filles sur music
[Musique]
leader est morte
je pense qu'à un moment où il faut
utiliser les grands moyens humains à
michele blind tu vois ta soir hier bien
sûr papa papa pas encore au pic est pas
encore ma soir il y avait un potentiel
je mets toi n'importe où mais n'est pas
parce qu'ils soufflent à oued souf par
ailleurs dit m'a demandé de me voir
ailleurs alors c'est
très bien attention
[Applaudissements]
le meilleur des blind test avec laurent
qui gagne quand même très souvent c'est
maintenant
[Musique]
alors le thème du blind test aujourd'hui
c'est le bistouri c'est à dire des
chanteurs et des chanteuses qui ont eu à
faire la chirurgie esthétique c'est en
hommage évidemment à rock'n roll
évidemment vous aviez vous a dit j'ai
fait du botox donc j'avais jamais voilà
du bon temps ça devait être très mal
fait parce que je pense qu'il y en a qui
on sent que c'est plutôt bien réussi
mais moi j'étais un peu momifié alors ça
m'a fait peur rachète un blanchiment de
l'anus mais je n'en parle pas par pudeur
rapide sur téléfoot vous jouez tous
contrebas fille attention brancher la
guitare
on tenait le temps mort moi jacques odm
abbas 1 2 3 4 et non
[Musique]
je vais vous dire
il n'a rien fait c'est une légende
regardez là ouais ouais c'est vrai je
suis content d'avoir mis carla bruni
elle n'a rien fait on continue on se
concentre
à nouveau
fresnoy proches tout en veillant à
moi pour zazie un point pour laurent
baffie vous comptez en régie attention
emma
et thérèse accepté
je t'aime
agence e
une connerie de la m ben oui rien n'a
rien emma
[Musique]
tabata potsdam nantis n'ont rien fait
ils ont rien fait les gens ball dames
avec cyril hanouna mais euh je crois que
c'est un problème ils ont une maladie de
l'enfant je pense qu'ils ont là mais
maintient ses défauts
mais ils ont fait la géorgie pour
essayer de réparer sa part voit bien la
charge et
uma
[Musique]
et il sait
je suis
oui
c'est
[Musique]
ailleurs perso
j'ai magnifique
titre a sonné bon attention
emma
twitter oui oui j'ai pas où sont les
femmes patrick juvet
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'endroit quel point c'est
dangereux de s'endormir prête à nicolas
[Rires]
[Musique]
douchez 6
et
alors
mateschitz le
vilain soit paquet du soir
consensus
et
les taupes est un généreux une mauvaise
photo et voilà on se retrouve on
rappelle que verdi son attention et ma
élargit l'offre
[Applaudissements]
non
d'où l'importance de mettre une bonne
crème solaire
attention c'est qu'on sent à mon avis
cela parlé à michel fau
[Musique]
maintenant allez on se fait un petit
super banco anticipant comme celui ou
celle qui va répondre à la question
suivante aura gagné le blind test et
sera obligé de m'y mets une célébration
de foot je sais quand les joueurs de
foot marque un but ils font des trucs
des dans ses pages des perles
chante l'apport envie de devenir
attention je suis par banco et non
[Applaudissements]
ils n'ont rien fait je sors de ce corps
[Musique]
attention se concentre et mal
je tiens si pire ah oui la chaire visage
je ne savais plus comment faire
et oui ah oui ophélie winter
suite
[Musique]
c'est
pour la guimauve alors comment ça se
passe au foot quand on gagne pas eu lieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la
voile est trés belle justement vous êtes
sur ces 8 on est toujours dans le grand
milan était un ami thierry ardisson et
laurent baffie
ce soir on fait le bilan quel moment se
remémorant chaque instant à parler des
histoires d'avant comme si on avait 50
ans
[Musique]
marché bio c'est bah ouais mais j'ai le
jeu mature en commentant ses doigts
loeb
a évité de mes pouvoirs
le font-ils a hérité de le pouvoir
regarder vont pouvoir mais de renverser
bon verre regardé par magie de l'équipe
va revenir dans le vert
[Applaudissements]
là ce soit on fait le bilan thierry
ayant notre bilan après vous êtes en
prime avec plein d'invités merveilleux
daphné bürki kara luciani chimène badi
nagui stéphane plaza et guillaume ii
contient seulement entre un très bon
camp après les invités merveilleux et
juste après la 21h 21h30 après cette
émission ses collègues mars au stade il
a de quoi il ya des invités merveilleux
qui vont venir
alors les téléspectateurs le sable mais
je le rappelle au cas où même si ça peut
paraître évident l'une des qualités
c'est la discrétion et attention il a
toujours tenu sa parole et là le grand
moment vous rencontrez un humoriste
célèbre dont je tairai le nom
et qui vous dit tu sais iris
tu la plus belle femme de l'univers et
là vous lui répondez ben oui canard on
m'a élu
alors c'est cool vous avez pas dit que
c'était qu'à madame c'est chouette mais
d'ailleurs thierry il aime tellement
être discret que quand il est discret il
est vraiment très discret vous avez vu
j'en ai pas trop parler d'isabelle
boulay était tous un peu quand même un
peu c'est dans l'un de ces artistes mais
moi je vais voir audrey je vais parler
vous un peu indécis
et puis bon balle est en baisse et la
raab on va pas se mentir marc yevou
divorcé quand va-t-elle vous avez trompé
avec un emirati et vous l'aviez tromper
aussi ouais je me permet d'entrer dans
les détails de sa mais nous oui
merci laurent non mais ça on n'a pas
envie de poser la question on a envie
d'avoir la réponse nous dit rien parce
que votre attaché de presse m'a appelé à
trois jours en me disant surtout ne lui
parle pas de gilet jaune et toi discret
non c'est pas ça c'est que je m'appelle
pas michel drucker je m'appelle thierry
ardisson l'obligé le public attend quoi
c'est comme moi leblanc test
oh là là voilà
et puis un moment comment dire à la
limite de poser des questions que les
autres ne posent pas pourquoi pas mais
de là à poser des questions que mère
juive par exemple point gastambide il
est en couple avec sabrina ouazani oui
vous êtes au courant oui il a été lourd
non mais ça va bien ça va il ya kadri
que je comprends pas parce que moi je
vous trouve fait un coup de formidable
pourquoi tu ne les pousse pas ah oui
allez
peut-être que voulait faire ta de
modifier l'arrêté est arrêté non
pourquoi c'est une bonne question et je
vais y réfléchir
il évoquait jan decleir dans tournez
manège c'est fou alors après le problème
d'aller poser des questions sur la vie
privée des gens c'est que c'est un coup
à se casser le nez quoi voir à se faire
casser le nez d'ailleurs je leur ai dit
que je ne voulais pas parler mais a bien
raison parce que ton contrat stipule que
tu ne dois pas dire du mal de francs
stylisé paille encore une fois qu'ils
les pas lourds légers faire
mais ce que j'adore chez vous c'est que
vous essayez toujours d'aller chercher
la petite bête comme avec laëtitia milot
a et alors il ya des jeux de société
coquin mais n'est pas vraiment d'exemple
quoi ça c'est pour être bien dans son
couple d'accord je dois pas non plus un
joueur et d'abri à des jeux coquins non
je dis juste je dis juste des conseils
pour annoncer dans le bouquin yariv ben
ouais sauf que le souci c'est karine loi
aller choper le scout bah du coup on se
dévoile un peu soi même sur sa vie
privée et puis parfois on en dit trop
parce que c'est le jeu du départ
exemples orangettes indé et sur chaque
puck du d il ya une position différente
des par exemple il a été trahi la wet
imagine qu'à calais double pipe mais
réunion c'est que thierry quand il parle
de sexe bah voilà il ya des déclarations
qu'on préférait ne pas avoir prononcé
vous avez déclaré donc aux grosses têtes
que vous n'aimiez pas le sac et que vous
regardiez le plafond mais ça s'appelle
rester sur le dos alors non mais une
explication d'un spécialiste peut-être
une disco fiancée position complètement
renversée pour que les gens il peut
aller de la coupe il peut se il peut se
toucher d'aller pied jusqu'à la tête par
exemple vous la pénétrer en l'envers il
faut voir la [__] un peu plus lente
parce que tu perds déjà dix centimètres
pour leur part le tournoi des mecs super
mes sentiments mais je vais le rester
grand chose
accueillir celui qui a remplacé stéphane
guillon gaspard pouces est à nouveau
stéphane guillon d'ailleurs je n'aime
pas trop le terme de remplacer jeu c'est
pas très joli je préfère succéder
remplacer on dirait qu'il lui a piqué sa
place alors que succéder il a attendu
qu'ils soient morts pour lui piquer sa
place les partis de belgique pour venir
en france l' inverse d'un exilé fiscal
bon il a perdu en demi-finale de la
coupe du monde s'en est pas remis non
mais si c'est pas grave je demande
d'accueillir du coup très
chaleureusement monsieur alex vizorek
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien vu alex ne sais pas si tu as vu
thierry il est toujours extrêmement
content de t'accueillir
attention giggle jingle
attention ding ding ding attention
dingle attention dingle dingle je vais
essayer de lancer le jingle aussi bien
quand on traite un deux trois digues ou
là
haut
n'oublions que tous ensemble on ne peut
pas attendre oit 4
c'est fou d'un tir il est toujours
extrêmement content de t'accueillir mais
il ya des fois où ils oublient ce qu'il
doit faire et du coup c'est toi qui es
obligé de lui rappeler on y va on ira
quand j'aurai dit jingle ben c'est ça
que j'attends moi jingle on est parti
voir des parties jingle
petit jingle
et puis à défaut il n'a pas envie du
tout
bon jingle
[Rires]
alors justement ce qui a caractérisé
avec cette saison c'est que c'est toi
qui faisait des jingles toi même ri on
peut le voir il a commencé avec une
pauvre cymbales voilà et puis la
terminer tels des bands des fêtes de
bayonne
patricia 1 sauf que lui était tout seul
donc c'était plus rémy bricka du coup
voilà
alors alex l'homme orchestre le mot
requête pour tous ceux qui ont loupé ce
virtuose des instruments qu'on n'utilise
jamais dans un orchestre un ghetto
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et on commence par l'événement de la
semaine ont orchestré à grands dj de la
halle en revient au sens c'est un petit
coup et d'autre
elle appelle également
les gréements de foire et du conte salut
dont la gestion est prometteur on peut
se remettre un petit coup du come on for
oui j'ai bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on peut vérifier s'ils visent
haut et plus fort qu'un orchestre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la grande force alex est de ne
jamais oublier les amateurs de jeux de
mots et qui est impressionnable avec un
jeu de mots à par laurent ruquier les
enfants et tu n'oublies jamais les
amateurs de jeux de mots et les enfants
pm importe tous le feu vert du comité
d'éthique et pour la pma c'est normal
que le feu soit au vert
[Applaudissements]
voire prestigieux debout ou et les
amateurs de jeux de mots se régale sur
la wii petit jeu de mots de qualité ya
aussi des enfants qui le regardent oui à
des blocs pour les enfants aussi
bon il faut des blagues pour les enfants
jeux de belote pour les enfants mais je
vais terminer par une bonne plus
familial parce que c'est important à nos
yeux un public jeune
petite blague pour les enfants c'est
important les jeunes qui nous regardent
olivier les enfants aussi
il ya des enfants qui regardent il faut
qu'ils infligent une de temps en temps
alex vizorek le cardinal barbarin
[Applaudissements]
enfants bilan évidemment extrêmement
positif cette saison mais alex il a
d'ailleurs la très grande délicatesse de
dire aux gens quand une blague et soit
pas bonne soit surévaluée
je m'attendais
la plus brillante elle aimerait plutôt
très bien
devant dix ans je suis un peu gêné de
cette base mais passons
[Musique]
ouais c'est la branche belge hln je ne
rends pas compte
[Applaudissements]
honnêtement bien l'info chimiques et
c'est là où
émergent été démasqué en tout cas c'est
quoi je veux dire quand une blague le
poids bonne enfin bon par contre pas son
nom quand elles sont très bien alors là
il les adore ari gold ah oui
sur france inter j'ai fait un gros
carton en la racontant celle là
elle est mignonne
est en pré salé l aller bosser
ouais c'était un truc de professionnels
un foutu comme eh oui
[Applaudissements]
moi je pense que la grande difficulté
d'alex cette saison c'était de terminer
sa vanne avant que d'autrui de la
termine
ne reçoit pas dit du parlant
we have l euro il y avait aussi les
invités qui pouvait être très rapide
savoir on regarde affaire dupont de
ligonnès la maison vendue avec une
grosse plus-value à comme quoi ça valait
la peine de refaire la terrasse
et il y voit arriver à avoir le sol au
web avec c'est de l'humour noir et de le
voir et d'avant des ophtalmologues
écrivain macron pour demander un
moratoire sur les lbd40 donc contre les
flash ball ce sont les ophtalmologues
qui se mobilisent j'imagine que contre
la politique taxatoire du gouvernement
on doit s'attendre une implication des
proctologue
la voir arriver
[Applaudissements]
à l'école ils les voient arriver de loin
une femme accuse son dentiste d'avoir
introduit son sexe dans sa bouche
pendant une consultation
heureusement qu'elle n'est pas au rendez
vous chez le proctologue
je les fais rapidement parce que je
sentais qu'elle pouvait venir de là
c'est lui je ramène la complice et voilà
je vous rappelle et les prénoms des
enfants maddox pax zahara zylo et knox
et l'ordonnancé
cema val salva envers
tout le temps j'ai une balle alors il a
fait avancer déconnecté c'est un
professionnel sauf que nous on bosse et
l'huile on approuve face
à la différence d'autres l'auront baby
nous c'est qu'il arrive les mains dans
les poches il sait même pas qui sont les
invités ils ont heureusement parce que
parfois je viendrai pas
et l'autre drame de cette saison il n'y
a pas un truc avec laurent un running
gag mais si c'est qu'ils expliquent les
blagues à son voisin
s'il a parfois pour qui c'est nécessaire
c'était compliqué et on commence par la
politique française le week end au ski
de macron a fait polémique
et c'est vrai que moi j'ai une image
perso que qu'on a dégoté voilà on
l'entend presque chanter et un canter
reverrai-je pays debout
[Applaudissements]
jadis un montage
macron a souhaité cette semaine sagesse
à la septuagénaire blessés à nice et la
gauche s'est indignée évidemment c'est
gonflé de la part de macron quand même
d'appeler à la sagesse quelqu'un calage
de sa mère techniquement la guidage sa
femme mais
oui la balance
pas l'air
c'est là pas de chance à l'extérieur et
son successeur est bien c'est françois
de rugy et là je pense qu'on peut parler
d'un choix du charisme de la part de la
grèce maquereau ou peut-être le choix de
la cohérence parce que françois de rugy
pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas bien
il a été maire et puis l'été au parti
socialiste et puis il a été au
gouvernement en marche c'est donc
pertinent qu'avant de s'engager vraiment
à fond dans l'éolien macron choisissent
une girouette
[Applaudissements]
m'explique il
est tellement con
objets suivants ça c'est la voilà ça
c'est la classe malgré la séparation
elle a laissé la bagnole mimie mathy
[Musique]
parce que les petites
galères le pape françois refuse la
démission du cardinal barbarin invoquant
la présomption d'innocence et c'est
normal moi ça m'étonne vraiment pas que
le pape constituaient barbarin comme
présumés innocents je vous rappelle que
marie est toujours présumé vierge
dans la foulée
[Applaudissements]
people toujours johnny hallyday sa
porsche a finalement été vendue à 85000
euros ils ont eu du mal à trouver un
acheteur faut dire que si elle consomme
autant que son propriétaire je compense
sa est refroidi certains et les brèves
états unis le pentagone développe un
milliard de dollars pour le mur de trump
1 milliard de dollars pour construire un
mur ça fait beaucoup de briques non il
faut des blagues pour les enfants gdblog
pour les enfants 21 de ses coûts
je commence par mon pays avec cette
information qui vient de belgique voici
donc les poutres que l'entreprise belge
va vous apporter en france pour
consolider notre dame de paris et saufs
vouloir me vanter je peux vous dire que
les poutres belge c'est du solide
oui c'était dégoûtant connaît
[Applaudissements]
oui c'était ça
[Musique]
brûler lui ça me
j'ai compris
rigolo et que ça abusé souvent sud à
côté bien sûr sachet de réinviter si
l'on regarde le plus contre détroit
c'est celui d'auch qui se trouve avec ma
fille messieurs il lui explique
reconnaît que ça te permet de prendre
une respiration oui si je me suis fait
pour viatique et l'autre ton dernier
drame est ce que tu connais ton dernier
drame
non les molières ah non ça paie pas de
mine avec des bons mots hier non c'est
pas non c'est pas un drame si l'on est
est ce que tu connais le sujet que tu as
le plus évoqué cette saison des fêtes de
belgique à l'acte ou
non mais attends il a qu'une et toi non
non non pas le doublé
oh la la
[Applaudissements]
on a gagné
mais je vous demande de zinc
je vous emmène
là où il est super pro ouais c'est qu'il
a un micro sur saab est au micro
sur les couilles
[Rires]
on m'a fait la thur brachetti
alors c'est le maillot d'adil rami la
terrasse à vie mais bon j'ai pas fini
mais c'était quoi le score de france
belgique 1-0 les açores la récupérer à
la rentrée c'était un oisillon je
n'avais plus de nice était
là mais en même temps il avait tiré
henry comme entraîneur c'est lui qui
expliquait comment tirer au but et c'est
vrai que vous
allez du coup on regarde
la rixe et au casque benalla était en
possession de la coupe du monde trois
jours après la finale alors d'abord en
tant que belge si vous voulez je me suis
dit c'est vrai que la coupe du monde on
la donne vraiment à n'importe qui cette
année
je m'y attendais un peu ouï dire la
presse quand la punaise et puis j'ai
relativisé j'ai dit bon ben il la mérite
un peu banale agir pendant la coupe du
monde il a eu autant de temps de jeu
qu'adil rami
et en même temps par rapport à giroud
benalla au moins quand il frappe il
frappe à gratter is you les
probants aux enchères ses crampons de la
finale de la coupe du monde franchement
n'achetaient pas c'est pas une bonne
affaire acheter les crampons d'adil rami
1 qui n'ont pas servi à la
non aux femmes c'est sa spécialité à
philippe schamp ci avec sa série
doggystyle voilà c'est là il m'a redonné
goût au football après cette demi-finale
volée à la belgique par la france ouais
j'ai encore et encore le sommet alors
bon anniversaire didier deschamps didier
deschamps fait fêté cette semaine ses 50
ans 50 ans et tout non
un footballeur brésilien dédie son but à
bolton arrow d'un salut militaire
gina faut apparemment mais c'est pas sûr
mais apparemment olivier giroud avait
prévu de rendre hommage au maréchal
pétain si marqué un but avec les bleus à
la coupe du monde ouf on le saura jamais
mais
la suivante terrasse assez gênant à
destination de düsseldorf leur avion
atterrit par erreur à edimbourg et bat
paravent il saigne au pilotage olivier
giroud
c'est pas aujourd'hui parce qu'il a
marqué ce et de cm contre l'islande
beaux bons amis ils visaient 2,8 de la
moldavie mais les niveaux de préserver
une faute
mbacké il le dit l'argent dans le
football c'est vraiment indécent kilian
si tu nous regardes je vais te laisser
mon rib comme ça si tu veux tu expliquer
de cette culpabilité tu n'hésites pas
mba pc le mec qui en plein milieu d'une
part tous deux dits bordel et l'amour
dans tout ça tu vois
[Musique]
et que nos villes quand les belges eux
lutte contre la pollution taxant les
véhicules propres mais français
[Musique]
ce qu'on veut c'est une juste vengeance
puisque vous nous avez taxer la dernière
coupe du monde de football passe pas ça
ça passe pas en grosses sommes grosses
sommes
le trophée du vainqueur garenne thomass
a été volé on a volé son trophée et
jeudi c'est dingue tous les trophées
importants ont été volés cette année je
rappelle donc avant celui du tour de
france c'est déjà la coupe du monde qui
avait été volée à la belgique par la
france et
je suis très clair oui un petit peu
jeune j'ai le sol
et un mba puis à clairefontaine sur les
traces de son frère kylian il ya un
deuxième mbp qu'arrive mais qu'on lui
ligature les trombes à cette dame moi je
veux pas que la belgique elles perdent
dix fois tu as du monde de pièges en
conflit
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs il paraît que le qatar aurait
déjà fait une offre de 500 millions
d'euros pour s'offrir les deux couilles
du père de killian m
[Applaudissements]
je continue à rien et où la première
année ils étaient encore très france
inter quand même un petit à petit
service musée baptisé 1 autant dire que
sur france inter sa vraie ambassade
mais je le vois dans les couloirs
vraiment les gens ne lui parle plus est
ce que tu veux conclure cette petite
c'était un bonheur d'être à votre
compagnie s'y tenait bon merci ohlala
c'est le moment de se quitter est un
gros merci à tous ceux qui misent ont
suivi cette saison qui nous ont aidés à
préparer cette belle émission on se
retrouve tout de suite après la q
avez-vous tiré
avec la bureautique à l'outil années
chez man made in eyes est bonne grâce à
guillaume de tonquédec s'est tout de
suite sur ces 8
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu